hi guys Justin hey Walt here joined by
Ty rube reporting to you live from the
area right behind the stage so there is
some craziness with this far cry stuff I
think ty can explain that a little bit
better than I can though yeah I'm not
going to talk about the game at all what
I'm going to talk about is you know pax
is interesting like you always have the
most bizarre booths at pax and whoever
has been to the show before knows that
they can get really extravagant and
crazy so me and Danny are walking out
yesterday where we're walking by a bunch
of like that microsoft booth sony booth
and we finally end at the far cry 4
booth and we didn't even know it was the
far cry 4 both what we saw were like a
giant elephant and a Snow Leopard now
these are actually people that are
waiting in line to dress in these giant
suits what you can see right here now on
the screen and they had like these
wrestling matches and it's like the
Octagon like there's like some Joe Rogan
type guy in there yelling at people and
this elephant is throwing this guy all
over the place like he's like a rag doll
it's hilarious so but we had no clue
what it was or like what is this for we
have no idea it's just these are just
both participant like people line up to
do this they're not like fighting a real
wrestler or something no no like these
are two people waiting in line probably
signing waivers making sure that Ubisoft
doesn't get sued or some [ __ ] like that
and then like look at this guy he just
throws them all over the place it's not
this crazy so that is the kind of [ __ ]
you'll see a pact it's a little a little
ludicrous I didn't even play for cry at
all so I've no idea what that game is
like other than that stuff that's been
shown the trailers and whatnot but it
was it's amazing it's great pax is fun
and that's the way you really want to
show off a game like that is by putting
people on animal suits and having them
fight to the death oh yeah I mean and
then they had like Tiger costumes too
and this elephant is gonna kick the show
this guy watch way he just throws him
right here against the fence it's
amazing and like I think they're hurting
each other I have no idea it's crazy so
if you're at the show go watch that and
then if not look for this we I think we
actually shot something for it will show
later today or something oh that is so
brutal like they were just really
throwing them around the stage but maybe
moving over to something that's a little
bit more light a little bit more
family-friendly Ori in the blind forest
it's again we've seen a couple times but
you finally got to try it out yourself
yes it's the it's the one thing that's
going to make me buy an xbox one now and
it's the only game I've actually play so
far on the show floor but it is
a beautiful game you play as like this
spirit guardian thing and you have like
this little like a sidekick that kind of
he helps you out or she helps you out
i'm not sure what it is but it's like
this spirit thing and you basically you
know you level up you earn more
experience this then you can go get more
skills that actually let you have access
to other parts of the world it's a very
Metroidvania type game yeah i mean
they're actually they took an
inspiration from metroid have actually
said this is kind of like you know that
this game was made by metroid metroid
fans that love that the franchise made
by some explosion people as well the art
is beautiful it kind of reminds me of
the UV art engine from like games like
Raymond and whatnot but it's a it's a
beautiful game made by moon studios and
and comes out later this year it looks
awesome so I love the design of that
that main character it's kind of a mix
between a cat and a I don't know what it
is exactly yeah it's weird so he like
Ori is like this creature who is like
adopted by like this mother type figure
in the game and then like you know she
gets kidnapped and it becomes like you
know a story of liking of trying to find
your mom going exploring to this forest
so it you know it's a light-hearted game
but I think it does speak on some
serious themes and it's fun it's cool
it's beautiful it's gorgeous yeah it
gives you that vibe of like you know
like things try think of just something
similar other than just like you know
either like random like our base games
that are like more like but you get it I
mean it borrows a lot of influences from
from things like Studio Ghibli like you
see some of the creatures there in the
background and it's dark and I wouldn't
say scary but that the tone of it can
can shift wildly just just like a good
studio ghibli film where you know can be
very family friendly and fun to watch
but at the same time kind of dark and
scary at times yeah I mean the UM you'll
help me out there's that was the the
black and white gate limbo okay so like
yeah it kind of gives me that type of
feeling we're like you don't know
exactly what's happening but you you
still feel a connection to the character
into the world and then like you know at
the very end you you you know you I
don't want to spoil in before anybody as
I played it but statue limitations it
has like that weird kind of heart felt
like very sad yet happy ending and I'm
assuming that's what Orie will go with
it just kind of feels like that kind of
game so and the last thing we spend some
time with was battle cry you and I both
played this you too
wind your team at the very last minute
into this multiplayer shooter and you
completely kicked our ass yes I
destroyed all of you but it's really fun
it takes a slightly different tactic to
some other shooters that the classes
that you have what what class were you
playing as in the game I was the
enforcer the enforcer is kind of the
basic class he has a lot more health a
lot more damage the enforces Oh psl I
mean I I got some tips from the devs
full disclosure I know some the guys
adult that game but at the same time
like I came on and they put me in the ax
foresters chair and like it it's it's
fun you get like this buzzer Kerr like
when you build up enough like rage you
can just unleash hell on like this
little section and you like we're going
through checkpoints trying to like you
know it's all by teamwork right and it's
a free-to-play game it was fun I enjoyed
it it was cool do it going through
though some capture the flag moments in
it very hectic and I really encourage
you guys to try it out if you're if
you're on the show floor that's probably
a pretty big line like there is for
everything attacks I think pax is more
about waiting that it is about anything
else it is it's it's insane how long
some of these lines get and then I mean
just going through the show floor
yesterday and trying to navigate and
health & E and Danny get through this
thing like with it with a Steadicam and
like going through the whole booth thing
this list it's nuts there were so many
people out there and there are some long
long lines it just reminds me a lot of
like last year as well and I feel like
it's just getting bigger and bigger and
it's also the pact is a vertical show
it's not just spread out over an entire
conference center it's well if they're
about six stories of the of the
buildings and trying to find things can
could be a little bit of a labyrinth and
you do have to sometimes fight enforcers
in order to get up to the next level I'm
not weak strong enough yet so I only get
up to level 4 and like you you graduate
you get the level 6 where all the fun is
apparently but no it's it's fun i think
i think obviously the weather's a little
crummy today but hopefully we'll get to
a point where like you know it's
extended an extra day right you know and
now there's pack self so you need to
make it to san antonio you can you can
catch it than you missed and you get to
try out all these games that we've been
playing for quite a long time I know
we've seen these at e3 we've seen these
at Gamescom and there's some things that
we haven't seen yet there are a couple
secrets I had to go to some behind
closed doors demos which unfortunately I
can't talk about but I'm really looking
forward to sharing some of the stuff
that I saw but I think the next thing
we're going to be talk
out here on the show floor Chris waters
I saw just walked in he was checking out
some civilization beyond Earth and
that's what our guys are going to be
talking about next